on y voit daniel caron et luc leblanc
nous ont guidés dans la caverne de saint
léonard
c'est ici en octobre qu'ils ont réalisé
leurs grandes découvertes
première étape franchir la galerie déjà
connu plan d'une quarantaine de mètres
est visitable chaque été depuis les
années 80 on avait identifié entre
autres avec la galerie au delà de la
grotte plus en plus corps fait nous
avons sont un peu plus loin là où en
fouillant les deux spéléologues ont
trouvé une couche de calcaire qui
semblait plus facile à briser apparu
alors une fissure puis le vide cet
endroit là c'est la lucarne que nous
avons été obligés à part celle d'un
petit trou grâce à un fond de bouteille
et qu'on a élargi et qui donnent
françois fleurs sur le plafond de la
grande bleue seront en terrain vierge
les quelques mètres qui suivent son
sportif il faut ramper s'accrocher à
cordes se tenir à l'échelle et voilà la
toute nouvelle galerie longue d'environ
275 m et haute de six mètres
ces lieux ont été formés lors de la
dernière période de glaciation il y à au
moins quinze mille ans septime ans c'est
vraiment impressionnant et là
actuellement je marche là où avant le
mois d'octobre
personne dans l'histoire de l'humanité
n'avait mis les pieds nous ne sommes
pourtant qu'à dix mètres sous le par pie
xii dans l'arrondissement saint léonard
la découverte est unique au québec de la
férule par personne
mais rennes paraît au plafond des
dizaines de stalactites assez
exceptionnel parce que dans les
conditions québécoise il faut presque
mille ans pour que se crée un petit
centimètre de stalactites puits au fond
de la grotte
c'est tout cristalline et ai touché qui
provient de la nappe phréatique
montréalaise
nous n'avançons pas plus loin mais les
deux spéléologues l'ont fait et nous
on fournit des photos par une escalade
nous avons rejoint par passages
supérieurs qui lui nous emmener à la
suite de cette gaine rivaux convoite le
plateau et kimoce poursuit sur plus
d'une centaine de mètres en fait nos
profonds les parois ils sont encore plus
lisse et verticale et le plafond de rock
impeccable dit daniel caron et on se
fout je joue pour l'instant on est
arrêté donc à se connaître le parcours
et le plafond se rapproche de l'eau un
cadeau pour montréal et l'arrondissement
de saint léonard
nous avons commandé une étude pour
savoir exactement où ces galeries vont
se rendre une fois qu'on aura leur
rapport nous allons présenter sans au
public et par la suite j'imagine mais y
aura des visites un jour pas si lointain
qui sait le parc pie xii deviendra
peut-être une attraction incontournable
pour les amoureux de la nature et pour
les curieux ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio-canada m'ont rien